>>> TULSI GABBARD, THE
FORMER HAWAII DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN AND
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
SAYS SHE'S LEAVING HER
PARTY FOR GOOD, ISSUING
THIS FIERY TAKE DOWN AHEAD
OF THE MIDTERMS.
>> I CAN NO LONGER REMAIN
IN TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THAT'S UNDER THE
COMPLETE CONTROL OF AN
ELITIST BE CAB ALF
WARMONGERS, DRIVEN BY
COWARDLY WOKENESS, WHO
DIVIDE US BIRACIALIZING
EVERY ISSUE AND STOKING
ANTI-WHITE RACISM.
I BELIEVE IN A GOVERNMENT
THAT'S OF THE PEOPLE, BY
THE PEOPLE, AND FOR THE
PEOPLE.
UNFORTUNATELY TODAY'S
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DOES NOT.
INSTEAD, IT STANDS FOR A
GOVERNMENT THAT IS OF, BY,
AND FOR THE POWERFUL
ELITE.
I'M CALLING ON MY FELLOW
COMMON SENSE INDEPENDENT
MINDED DEMOCRATS TO JOIN
ME IN LEAVING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO TO JESSICA
TARLOV.
MAYBE NOT A COMPLETE
SURPRISE SHE WOULD HAVE
DECIDED TO LEAVE, BUT SHE
DIDN'T ANNOUNCE BECOMING A
REPUBLICAN, BUT LEAVING
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> DOWN ONE.
WE WERE ALREADY DOWN THAT
ONE, PROBABLY EVERYBODY
ELSE WHO SAYS THEY'RE
DEMOCRAT AND IS SUPPORTING
HER ONLINE OR TUNING IN,
THAT'S PART OF A SHOW, SHE
WILL HAVE A NEW 30 MINUTE
SHOW.
TULSI GABBARD HASN'T BEEN
A DEMOCRAT FOR A VERY LONG
TIME.
IT IS NOT BECAUSE I AM
PISSED OFF SHE CRITICIZED
THE 2016 PRIMARY PROCESS,
UPSET DEBBIE WASSERMAN
SCHULTZ, SHE HAS BEEN
VINDICTIVE AND SPITEFUL
AND ANGRY TOWARDS
DEMOCRATS.
SHE HAS ATTACKED OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SHE I THOUGHT IN THE LAST
PRIMARY, 2020 PRIMARY, SHE
WOULD HAVE BEEN HAPPIER IF
DONALD TRUMP ENDED UP
WINNING.
SHE DOES THINGS THAT ARE
COMPLETELY INEXPLICABLE.
I AM CERTAINLY NOT GOING
TO SIT HERE AND SAY SHE
HAS ANY DIRECT TIES TO
RUSSIA, I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU END UP IN POSITION
THEY REFER TO YOU AS OUR
GIRLFRIEND ON RUSSIAN
STATE TV.
>> YOU CAN'T CONTROL THAT.
>> YES, YOU CAN.
>> HOW?
>> YOU CAN DO THINGS LIKE
NOT GO ON TELEVISION AND
SAY THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE IN THE U.S. IN TERMS
OF THE FREE PRESS ISN'T
THAT DIFFERENT FROM WHAT'S
GOING ON IN RUSSIA.
THEY THROW JOURNALISTS OUT
WINDOWS IN RUSSIA.
WHAT HAPPENS HERE, MAYBE
YOU DON'T GET TO ASK YOUR
QUESTION.
SHE WENT TO VISIT ASSAD IN
2017 WITHOUT TELLING PARTY
LEADERSHIP AND CAME BACK
AND SAID THAT THE PEOPLE
SHE MET SUPPORTED HIM,
THIS IS SOMEONE GUILTY OF
TERRIBLE WAR CRIMES.
STEVE BANNON LIKED HER SO
MUCH THAT HE HAD TO HAVE A
TRUMP TO YOUR MEETING
AFTER WINNING THE
ELECTION.
WHY WOULD STEVE BANNON
TAKE SUCH A SHINING TO
TULSI.
>> WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO, FIRST WITH RUSSIA, NOW
WITH BANNON.
YOU SAY IF SOMEBODY ELSE
LIKES YOU, THAT'S ON YOU.
I CAN'T HELP IT.
I HAVE SOME FANS THAT CAN
BE KIND OF STRANGE.
THAT AIN'T MY FAULT.
>> BANNON ISN'T JUST KIND
OF STRANGE.
IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRATIC
OFFICIAL AND STEVE BANNON
AND DONALD TRUMP THINK
YOU'RE ACES AND WANT TO
MEET WITH YOU, WANT TO
CONSIDER YOU FOR BEING IN
THE ADMINISTRATION.
>> IT IS NOT JOE BIDEN'S
FAULT THAT JOY REID LIKES
HIM, BUT SHE'S A NUT CASE.
>> ARE YOU COMPARING STEVE
BANNON AND JOY REID?
>> I FEEL THE SAME ABOUT
JOY REID YOU PROBABLY DO
ABOUT BAN NONE.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE
AMERICANS THAT DON'T MIND
BEING CONNECTED TO DONALD
TRUMP, IS THERE SOMETHING
WRONG WITH THEM?
>> MAYBE.
>> CUT IT OUT.
LET'S GO BACK TO TULSI.
THIS IS VERY INTERESTING.
WE JUST SPOKE ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS, VICE PRESIDENT,
THAT THEY CHOSE BASED ON
IDENTITY POLITICS, A WOMAN
WHO CAN'T GET OUT OF HER
OWN WAY TO DISCUSS
ANYTHING WHICH SHE HAS THE
POWER, SHE HAS THE ABILITY
TO GET THINGS DONE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND IN THE WORLD.
SHE IS A HALF WIT COMPARED
TO OTHER VICE PRESIDENTS.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
YOU HAVE TULSI GABBARD WHO
PUT HER LIFE ON THE LINE
FOR THIS COUNTRY COMPARED
TO THE HALF WIT WE HAVE AS
VICE PRESIDENT WHO CAN'T
EVEN ADDRESS THE ISSUE
SHE'S SUPPOSED TO.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING,
I GIVE HER CREDIT CALLING
OUT WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, DNC,
WHEN BERNIE SANDERS WAS
EDGED OUT BY HILLARY
CLINTON, WHEN SHE GOT THE
QUESTIONS FROM WHAT'S HER
NAME THAT SAID WE WERE
CRITICIZING HER BECAUSE
SHE WAS A GOOD CHRISTIAN
WOMAN, WHAT WAS HER NAME,
DONNA BRAZILE.
LET'S TALK TURKEY.
THIS WOMAN, TULSI GASH ARD
IS EDUCATED AND FAR FROM
VINDICTIVE, SPITEFUL AND
ANGRY.
YOU CALL HER THOSE THINGS.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN THE
WOMAN --
>> YOU CALLED THE VICE
PRESIDENT A HALF WIT.
>> SHE IS A HALF WIT.
>> A COMEDY SHOW.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING,
YOUR PARTY MAKES FUN OF
HER, YOUR OWN PARTY RUNS
AWAY FROM HER.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN TULSI
GABBARD RAISE HER VOICE
AND SHE PUT HER LIFE ON
THE LINE.
DON'T YOU DARE CRITICIZE
HER.
>> BECAUSE YOU SERVED
DOESN'T MEAN YOU ARE FREE
OF CRITICISM THE REST OF
YOUR LIFE.
>> SHE WAS ON JOE ROGAN'S
SHOW, TALKED ABOUT
FRIENDSHIP AND POLITICS.
WATCH HERE.
>> LIKE IF YOU'RE A
DEMOCRAT AND YOU DECIDE TO
GO ON TUCKER CARLSON, FOR
INSTANCE, WHAT IS THAT
LIKE?
>> IT RANGES FROM PEOPLE
KIND OF LIKE GIVING YOU A
CYNICAL LOOK, LIKE WHOSE
SIDE ARE YOU REALLY ON TO
PEOPLE JUST OUTRIGHT
ENDING THAT FRIENDSHIP OR
THAT PROFESSIONAL
RELATIONSHIP BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH YOU.
>> HAVE YOU EXPERIENCED
THAT?
>> OVER AND OVER.
>> I HATE HEARING THAT,
JESSE.
POLITICS SHOULD NEVER END
FRIENDSHIPS EVER, BUT IT
DOES HAPPEN.
>> MY MOTHER DOESN'T SPEAK
TO ME ANY MORE.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK
TURKEY.
>> I HAD ENOUGH TURKEY,
TURKEY LEFTOVERS.
>> I DON'T WANT TO MAKE IT
PERSONAL ABOUT TULSI
GABBARD.
>> IT IS.
>> BUT SHE HAS A POINT HOW
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
UNRECOGNIZABLE FROM WHAT
IT USED TO BE.
THEY'RE MUCH MORE HAWKISH,
THEY'RE NOT THE PARTY OF
THE WORKING MAN, THEY'RE
THE PARTY OF COLLEGE
GRADUATES, ELITE
INSTITUTIONS, THE UPPER
CLASS, AND THEY DON'T TALK
ABOUT HEALTH CARE AND
EDUCATION AND JOBS ANY
MORE.
THEY TALK ABOUT JANUARY 6
ALL DAY.
OR GENDER AND RACE.
IT IS ANNOYING.
AND THE BIGGER POINT THAT
SHE'S MAKING IS THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF INSECURE,
SNOB OH LIBERALS DYING FOR
ACCEPTANCE.
THEY WILL SUBMIT TO
WHATEVER THE WOKE LANGUAGE
OF THE DAY IS JUST TO FEEL
EMBRACED BY THE ELITE
INSTITUTIONS, AND WHAT
THEY'RE REALLY ARE,
THEY'RE USEFUL IDIOTS,
BEING USED BY POWERFUL
PEOPLE TO SHUTDOWN DEBATE,
THEY'RE BEING USED BY
POWERFUL PEOPLE TO SAY
THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE
ALLOWED TO SAY, THIS IS
WHAT YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
SAY, SO POWERFUL INTERESTS
CAN MAKE THEIR MONEY AND
DO THEIR THING
UNINTERRUPTED.
THEY DON'T REALIZE HOW
USEFUL OF IDIOTS THEY ARE,
BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY LIFE,
IT GIVES THEIR LIFE
MEANING.
WITHOUT THAT, IT LACKS
>> TULSI GABBARD IS ON
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
ANYONE HAVE FINAL
COMMENTS?
>> YES, I WAS YELLING AT
JESSICA.
WHAT JESSICA IS
ILLUSTRATING AND OTHER
PEOPLE, OBVIOUS THING,
EVERY OPPOSING PARTY LOVES
IT WHEN SOMEBODY LEAVES
THAT PARTY, AND THE PARTY
THAT LOSES THAT PERSON
SAYS GOOD RIDDANCE.
LIKE LIZ CHENEY.
LIKE GO.
GO AWAY.
THAT'S HOW I WOULD FEEL.
LIBERALS WOULD BE LIKE
SHE'S A HERO, SHE'S A
HERO.
ALMOST LIKE THE MIRROR
IMAGE OF THIS.
IT IS.
SGLM TULSI IS A MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT PERSON.
>> THE OPPOSITE, LIZ
CHENEY RUNS ON BITTERNESS.
TALK ABOUT BITTERNESS, HER
ENTIRE LIFE IS BASED ON A
GRUDGE ABOUT TRUMP.
AT LEAST TULSI, THE THING
I LIKE ABOUT TULSI, IF SHE
WERE TO GIVE YOU TWO
OPINIONS, YOU COULDN'T
PREDICT A THIRD.
SHE'S A DEFINITION OF AN
INDIVIDUAL.
LIKE I DISAGREE WITH HER
ON 30, MAYBE 40% OF
THINGS.
BUT THE BOXES SHE TICKS
AREN'T THE BOXES THAT
KAMALA TICKS.
HERS ARE ACHIEVEMENTS AND
IDEAS.
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN SKIN
COLOR, WHERE SHE WAS BORN,
NOT WHERE SHE WAS BORN,
WHEREVER HER BACKGROUND
IS.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT MAKES
HER SO DIFFERENT.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN HER
ANGRY IN MY LIFE.
JUST LASTLY, I THINK SHE'S
GOING TO BE TRUMP'S VP.
THAT'S WHERE THIS IS
GOING.
I THINK WHEN SHE SAID THE
ANTI-WHITE RACISM, SHE
SAID SOMETHING MOST PEOPLE
CAN'T SAY.
THAT TAKES SERIOUS STONES
TO SAY THAT BECAUSE IT IS
TRUE.
I MEAN, IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THEY MADE IT REALLY
CLEAR THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU
CAN BE RACIST AGAINST
WHITE PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE IT COMING.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
EVERYBODY IS DESPERATELY
IDENTIFYING AS SOMETHING
ELSE.
NO, NO, I'M NOT WHITE.
EVERYBODY IS FINDING
SOMETHING ELSE TO BE.
THAT'S WHY YOU COME TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
YOU BECOME AN INDEPENDENT.
THEN YOU CAN BE WHO YOU
ARE, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
PRESENT.
>> 60% OF AMERICANS NOW
SAY THEY'RE INDEPENDENT.
BOTH PARTIES ARE IN THE
MINORITY.
I APOLOGIZE.
I THOUGHT I HAD GOTT